on va vous faire une interview dernier
coup pour neda
dernier coup dur
le dernier coup dur oui la candidature
de balladur alors oui il avait déjà 3 et
wii dernier coup de coeur
dernier coup de coeur pour l'interview
de françoise de panafieu dans l way qui
dit quoi parle dit beaucoup de choses et
elle landi et sa famille andy aussi
chose qui m'a intéressé c'est que sa
soeur dit quand elle était petite
il ya une grande famille cette famille
7,7 frères ou soeurs pour sept ou huit
et elle était la new line et donc été la
reine ouais et nous étions ses esclaves
et on lui apportait le savons les
chaussons entre donc sa masse ça m'a
vraiment intéressé un peu peut-être
aussi inquiétée par la pana fassis ici
très bien
vial dernier coup de poing d'un
collaborateur qui nous avons quel
respect comme étant un peu un peu loin
de mes préoccupations politiques au delà
dernier coup de folie il s'ouvre le
soutien permanent à jean tiberi
ouais dernier coup de foudre
bernadette chirac bernadette chirac
n'aurait pas trop avec votre femme vous
mois dernier google alors ça le dernier
coup violent c'est permanent
ouais mais cécilia c'était il ya une
heure et demie et les méchants faux pas
qui ressemble à un polluant 3 un peu
bled il faut savoir si ces raspoutine
richelieu les arts à napoléon iii
physiquement franchement c'est juste
aller plus loin dans la bataille
et vous savez que ce gars est fair
livres sur napoléon iii je suis la vie
beaucoup napoléon iii je sais rien
c'était un grand emprunt voilà dernier
coup de pub bassila c'est vraiment elle
vous aide pas beaucoup mais non mais
c'est bien parce que je trouve que c'est
quelqu'un qui dit ce qu'elle pense et
qui est vrai c'est bien ce gars est plus
beau que la sincérité de mon dernier que
vous c'est fini c'est fini
dernier coup de rouge et la cia deux
heures
oui vous avez bien lu qu'un effet la
cave de l'hôtel de ville langue j'ai
fait la cave de l'hôtel de ville
ouais quand même cette bouteille 500
sénat 15 mille bouteilles quinze mille
bouteilles mesdames messieurs et gbda
sur lequel veut le faire de plus
pistolet avant d'aller coup de chapeau
bien le coup le mot dernier coup de
chapeau c'est c'est celui que j'ai donné
à jean tiberi encore à sa sortie de
l'hôpital parce que ça correspondait à
ce moment là une campagne de presse
extravagante et je trouve que le courage
qui manifestent en permanence mérite un
vrai coup de chapeau
dernier coup de poker c'est celui qu'on
joue en ce moment c'est la partie qu'on
joue cependant c'est celui-là de l'année
coup de poker
et pour finir dernier foudre à
avant-hier très bien on a vu
merci bernard bled alors vous avez
regardé le match mercredi soir qu'ils
allaient bordeaux way for me l' énorme
non non très rare ces temps là les
prolongations étaient géniales unix
s'est jamais loin d'être dans le
football alors nous accueillons
maintenant vanessa demouy christophe
hogard de guerre